[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sozialismus
heute gibt es ein leckeres hauptgericht
ich werde einen hackbraten zubereiten
geht mach ich ganz gerne vor allem weil
er mit saft abgefüllt ist geschmacklich
erinnerte eigentlich schon ein bisschen
an micky fertig schon mal gemacht sie
waren auch mit schafskäse gefüllt
diese kleinen kritischen frikadellen
hier habe ich aber auf dem herd und
einfügen und natürlich von hackbraten
bisserl einfacher werden er wird einfach
im ofen vorbereitet und in gang gebracht
werden
er habe was habe ich noch mit wenig an
der paprika mit drin und werde später
ein bisschen salat und einfach selbst
gemacht agenda zu erreichen
und ich sage ich die quali karten für
den hack fahrten brauche ich 150
milliliter wasser 100 gramm reis in der
natur einen halben teelöffel 54 packt
beim rindfleisch entfernt hier habe ich
noch einen halben teelöffel kleine rote
paprika 200 g schafskäse und petersilie
ich liebe essen reis und sehen hier in
einem topf auf und ich nämlich reiss
profile linie auch brot oder sendet
wollte unbedingt ein bisschen zu binden
ich finde der reis gibt einfach von
wittchen eine andere konsistenz mit
heimatlos und locker und auch schön
saftig bleibt einmal auf höchster stufe
ich dass man den weg ins plus und was
braucht man das gleich über und während
der reife tier auftaucht kann ich schon
mal gibt's beim schreiben
[Musik]
da gebe ich bin deckel drauf und kann im
prinzip auch schon abschleifen decken
hier komplett durchwühlt und danach
warte ich noch gut abkühlen
jetzt geht es hier zum hackfleisch
herbst als vergebene preis und zum
hackfleisch wieder zurück kommt das eis
dann natürlich auch hier pfeffer salz
und freut sich ganz zur seite und wird
schon mal die paprika in kleine würfel
schneiden
[Musik]
die hofeigene gibt gewiss die beiden
gehackte petersilie mit hackfleisch da
kommt auch der reife dazu und das ganze
verkneten jetzt am besten mit dem hin
[Musik]
die freien wir wollten paprika stücke da
reibe ich noch die club of sale dass du
den knoblauch und afrika kommen dann in
die käserei
[Musik]
auch mittels zu bröseln und schafkäse
genommen aber ihr könnt auch zum
beispiel einen weichkäse optimistischen
bilder aber scharfe geschmack natürlich
[Musik]
ich nehme ich eine passform ich habe
ziele ecke gekauft haben etwas kleiner
ihr könnt aber auch eine auflaufform
nehmen und dann einfach so ein leib
formen nämlich die hälfte von nachdem
entweder macht ihr einen live cam oder
immer zwei mal auf einem pferd kämpfen
hier geschildert fliegen jetzt die
hälfte
ansonsten könnte die masse auftritten
und zwei markierte einkommen mache wird
am rand solle keine erhöhung damit am
rand etwa nicht aufläuft
[Musik]
jetzt gibt peter masser 1
das hat bei mir übrigens nur optische
gründe darf ich es mir dieser weißen
füllung so gemacht habe ansonsten könnte
nämlich auch den käse und die paprika
einfach komplett mit dem hackfleisch
vermischen falls ihr euch den
arbeitssprachen wollte
[Musik]
und joker martin hug paten auch ganz gut
vorbereiten abgedeckt im kühlschrank
liegen lassen und dann einfach kurz vor
dem verzehr in den ofen schieben und
zwar wieder hackbraten jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad ober
unterhitze gesagt und dann eine backform
perforierte vielleicht würde das fällt
jetzt raus kommst du in den backofen
hinein
deswegen habe ich die renten ein
fachlich und meine dauer bakulin schon
mit drin ganz unten drin dass sie jetzt
eben auch gut durchkommt und da kann es
ist schön einen monat später weniger
kurzarbeit
[Musik]
jetzt ist der hack art und fertig ich
habe den titel abkühlen lassen damit es
nicht verbrennen
und das schöne an das haben es ich kann
aufstehen
ich werde da unten aber das hängt nicht
mit dem konzept und auch nicht mit der
backform zusammen sondern mit man
verkaufen weil da einfach die unsere
hilfe
mit verboten und jetzt schneidet ein
stück davon abhaben
[Musik]
unter so reichlich wie bereits
angekündigt
dritter ist mit einem hohen fenster
wobei man das paket nicht mehr unbedingt
braucht denn man hat ja hier schon reife
dran aber der haftfrage fertig sein foto
im wunderschönen hacken und wenn ihr
auch mal reinschaut federte diesen
schönen rot-weißen kempf verstehen oder
und benny buch hat gerade telefoniert
und ihr nachbar so ist habe ich mit
ihrem liebes team wir probieren
[Musik]
ich bin gerade farbspiel so schön heißt
sie auch in den genuss dieses leckeren
handel kommen möchte dann geht auf
meinem blog auffällig - blog.de wir
werden demnächst hier noch betrifft noch
ein bisschen aus übrig und amira und
eder natürlich alle schüttelt mit dem
kopf schneller morath nein dann jedoch
völlig locker das steht noch mal einfach
webcams genau und wie gesagt mensch wie
paprika magischen ins rennen august
einfach auslegen irgendwas anderes
wobei ich finde das paprika davon immer
bei gut kommt und vor allem weil es im
kern innen drin ist ist auch nicht so
weiß der bleibt also viel spaß beim
nachmachen
[Musik]
er kriegt der salat